Facebook is expected to focus on changes
to its platform today at its annual
developer conference CEO Mark Zuckerberg
spent spoke to thousands of app
developers yesterday looking forward
after a major privacy scandal he hoaxes
in the rear view mirror
Zuckerberg says users will soon be able
to delete their browsing history he also
revealed a new online dating feature
John Blackstone is in San Jose where he
attended that keynote event John good
morning good morning well Mark
Zuckerberg also wants millions of
Facebook users to start wearing these
the company's new virtual reality
goggles he introduced yesterday but even
with Facebook's expansion into virtual
reality Zuckerberg had to recognize the
actual reality of the past few months
this is an important moment we need to
do more to keep people safe and we will
mark zuckerberg says he's doubling down
on his pledge to improve Facebook's
security giving users more control over
their privacy you're gonna be able to
use this tool to see the information
about the apps and websites you've
interacted with you'll be able to clear
all this information
Zuckerberg shied away from apologizing
for his company's recent shortcomings a
sharp departure from his testimony
before Congress just three weeks ago it
was my mistake
and I'm sorry to try to win back users
trust end attention Zuckerberg also
vowed to keep building unveiling a host
of new features and products we're
rolling out something that we call watch
party we're launching a new groups tab
we are announcing a new set of features
coming soon around dating Zuckerberg
says Facebook's dating service is
intended to help users find meaningful
long-term relationships there are 200
million people on Facebook who list
themselves a single so clearly there's
something to do here the announcement
sent shares of online dating company
matched plummeting 22 percent by the end
of the day Facebook they look at
whatever in the market and they try to
do it better but cyber security expert
Ahmed benefi says convincing Facebook
users its new products are secure might
still be an uphill battle
protecting the privacy of the of the
customers is a biggest thing
for them now so they can regain the
trust and Mark and his team this is one
of the toughest time they'd ever seen in
their life in response to Facebook's
dating service match group CEO Mandy
Ginsburg says she's surprised at the
timing given the amount of personal and
sensitive data that comes with this
territory
Facebook's entry will only be
invigorating to all of us
Liana Wow match clearly did not see that
news coming right taking a swipe just a
little bit of shame yeah we shall see